[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
55 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
good, thanks Francesc.
I'm away from you at the moment,
still at home in San Francisco.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
MARK MANDEL: But I'll be
joining you in LA shortly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I'm
already in LA-- LA office.
Very nice office designed
by Frank Gehry, nonetheless.
It's a pretty nice place to
be-- beach and everything.
Yep.
MARK MANDEL: Fancy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah.
See you soon.
But before that, we need
to record an episode.
So let's go with that.
[LAUGHING] We are going to
have a fun interview today.
I think it's a very
interesting interview.
We're going to interview
two members of the Manage
Infrastructure Team at
Google Cloud Platform.
And I'm going to try to say
their names even though I'm
sure I'm going to fail at this.
So we have Pawel and
Jeryz, Pawel Siarkiewicz
and Jerzy Foryciarz.
And I think that that is
probably the best I can do.
MARK MANDEL: Very well done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think it's very good.
I'm pretty proud.
So yeah.
We're going to be
interviewing them
about what is Management
Infrastructure
and why it is important,
and why it might
be the good solution for you.
So it's an interesting episode.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
I'm really interested in it.
For interest's sake you might
want to go back-- or not you
specifically, but
someone in the audience
might want to go back and
listen to our episodes
about continuing of the
Cloud and maybe even
the Google Compute Engine
or virtual machines
episode as well.
They might find them
particularly relevant.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think that the first episode--
no, the episode number two
was about that.
Compute as a continuum.
It was a very
interesting episode,
and maybe time to
refresh it one day.
Who knows?
But before we start
refreshing any episodes,
let's finished with this one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
after the interview,
we have a question of the week.
And it's about
our favorite topic
ever for questions of the
week, which is Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
Always keen to have Kubernetes,
about how you can lock down
your services inside Kubernetes
so you can control who
can access them and whatnot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So security, security, security.
But very important.
But before that, we're going
to go with our cool things
of the week.
And one of the cool
things of the week-- I
think it's really cool
for multiple reasons.
I'm kind of a geek
about this thing.
It's called time.
And time is the kind of
thing that is like, oh,
it's easy until you
start doing time zones.
And when you think time
zones are hard, especially
in Australia-- I
don't know what's
going on with that country.
But then you need to start
thinking about things
like leap seconds and
stuff like that, which
we will have one this year.
So we actually opened
an API to do this.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So we now have across Google, we
have these public NTP servers.
So if you haven't ever used--
well you probably have used NTP
but you don't realize it.
It's global services that are
provided to synchronize time
across machines.
And we now have these
public NTP servers
that are available for you to
use that do the leap smearing
for leap seconds, so
that your machines don't
do weird things when they
think 61 seconds is good time
to have in a minute.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah.
It is kind of cool.
There's a gif that
I really like,
which is a clock going--
it's 23, 59, and 58, all
the January-- no, December 31.
And it goes 57, 58, 59, 60.
So it counts 61 seconds in
the minute, which is actually
what will happen this year.
So yeah.
2016: longer than expected.
And it's a really cool thing,
because not only you get access
to time that is very precise.
You're actually
using load balancers.
So you get access to the closest
atomic clock in the data center
where your instance is running.
So it's incredibly accurate.
MARK MANDEL: That is very cool.
I didn't realize
that was the case.
That's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah
Probably way more accurate
that you will ever think.
So yeah.
It is incredibly powerful.
It's a very, very
powerful clock.
Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
that's really cool.
I like the second
cool thing of the week
because I like fast hardware.
We have a strategic
alliance with Intel,
which is pretty awesome.
And that means that we have
announced the upcoming Xeon
processor is going to
be available on Compute
Engine and other
virtual machines,
and available on
Google Cloud Platform.
So if you're keen
to be on the latest
and greatest in hardware,
that strategic alliance
is pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And I see that it
will-- yeah, it
will be in all of our flavors.
So standard [INAUDIBLE]
and high CPU's.
So it's going to be
available for whatever
you're trying to do.
You're going to get access
to pretty amazing processors.
That is very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's actually really cool.
So if you look
into the alliance,
there's stuff in there
about optimizing Kubernetes
for Intel architecture,
TensorFlow, IOT, security.
A lot of really cool stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And if you're interested
in joining the beta form--
because it will be open sometime
in 2017, it's as early as 2017.
But if you're interested
in testing it,
there's a beta program.
And we'll have a
link to the form
so you can apply to it
from the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: So it
sounds like it's
time for us to go talk Managed
Infrastructure with Pawel
and Jerzy.
Why don't we go do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm very pleased
to have two wonderful gentlemen
here with us today to talk to
us about an interesting thing
called Managed Infrastructure.
We have two product managers,
whose names I am most likely
going to massacre.
But I will try my very best.
Pawel Siarkiewicz and
Jerzy-- oh god-- Foryciarz.
Is that even remotely close?
JERZY FORYCIARZ:
No, it's pretty bad.
MARK MANDEL: That
was really bad, yeah.
Yeah.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: It was bad.
It's Foryciarz.
But you can totally go with it.
Much better than any of
the flight attendants
that are trying to do it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
How are you both doing today?
Pawel, how are you doing?
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ:
Very good, thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Good.
And Jerzy?
You seem to be doing well?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Good.
Good.
Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: So thank you
so much for joining us,
both of you.
I really appreciate you
both taking the time.
I'm really excited
about this conversation.
Before we get stuck
into the details,
though, let's talk
about who you are
and what you do here at Google.
Pawel, I'll pick you at random.
How about you go first?
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: Sure.
So I actually started
as a programmer
and spent most of my career
being a coder and a lead
and a technical director.
Kind of that usual path.
And then at some point I decided
to take a bit of a detour
into business and
pure management.
But it turns out I really did
just like building products,
and ended up as a
product manager at Google
and I've been here since
the beginning of 2016.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And you, Jerzy?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: So my career
actually started several years
ago when I was a
nuclear physicist.
And then I moved to the industry
and worked for several years
as an engineering
director at Motorola.
And then I moved
to Google, where
I was initially working on
Google TV, then on Google Now.
And two years ago, I
moved to Google Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is
a not very traditional way
to end up on Managed
Infrastructure.
Why don't you tell
us a little bit
about what do you mean by
Managed Infrastructure?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: OK.
Let me go first.
So Managed Infrastructure is a
suite of products and features
that are making the life
of a database easier.
So we tend to call it as
viewer DevOps notion, right?
Something where you
really don't need
to worry about your
infrastructure.
You can focus just
on your applications.
So in terms of what
we talk about in here,
we look at two
components, one of which
is the Managed Instance Groups.
And I'll explain in a
second what this is.
And the second one
is rightsizing.
So a Managed Instance
Group is a way
of creating virtual
machines in a repeatable way
on a massive scale.
So imagine you're
running a service.
This service, let's
say it's a web service,
and it has front end running
on a virtual machine.
But as the load is growing, you
need more and more connections
handled.
And at some point,
there is not enough
that there is a single machine.
So this system can be built
based on the Managed Instance
Group.
And all of the logistics related
to adding instances, removing
instances automatically
is served by auto scaler.
The fact that they're
kept alive and they
are recreated whenever
there's any problem
is done by auto healer.
And then you can
deploy a new version
of the software using app data
while your services are still
running.
So all of that, the
suite of products
we call Managed Infrastructure.
And now the second piece
of it is the rightsizing.
It's a way for us to tell you,
look, you're our great customer
and we don't want
you to overpay.
It's one way of saying it.
And second is,
look, we really see
that the setup on your machine
has too little of the memory
or not enough cords
to perform your task.
So we get you rightsizing
recommendations and a way
to quickly actuate it so
that you are in a good shape.
That's pretty much it.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
OK.
So it sounds like there's--
basically it sounds like this
is a way to manage virtual
machines in a very elastic way
that enables you to scale.
Excellent.
Cool.
So I guess my
question at this point
is, OK-- what sort
of applications
does this lend itself to?
Is there a particular set
of types of applications,
or I don't know, what sort of
requirements or restrictions
does this fit into?
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: So in
terms of the applications
that run well on MIG's,
there is a couple
of what I would call canonical
typical use cases that we see.
And there are some
that spin out of that.
But let me start with the
simple, typical uses cases.
And the first one is
anything that serves traffic.
Right?
So typically that
could be, let's say,
a web front end
that either connects
to a phone application that
is distributed to your users
or maybe it's just
a classic store.
And what makes it
really a good match
for Managed Instance Groups is
that first of all, your usage
is very dynamic.
Right?
So as your traffic grows with,
let's say, the local time,
you need suddenly a
lot more processing.
As much as twice or 10
times as much as you
need in your down times.
And so you really want to take
advantage of this auto scaling,
right?
Where as the traffic is
showing up in real time,
we'll be creating machines
in real time and scaling
up very, very quickly so
that you can take your peaks
and serve all of your customers.
And then as soon as
the traffic stops,
we'll get rid of
those machines, right?
So you don't have to be paying
for resources you don't use.
And typically those
services are stateless.
So each machine can basically be
brought up and then destroyed,
and it doesn't have
any local state.
So it is very flexible that way.
And the other use case that is
a very good usage of MIG's is
anything that can
or has to process,
let's say, lots of data
in a distributed fashion.
So maybe you're
analyzing financial data.
So you have 10,000 stock
quotes and each one
can be analyzed independently.
So that can be distributed
over lots of machines.
And then you want to do that as
you crunch through your data.
But the other part
of that workload
is that it's very
much on demand, right?
So new financial data
might show up or maybe you
have a new model that
you want to analyze.
And so you go from I need
none of this computed to I
need all of the
compute immediately,
as soon as you can give it
to me, to process through all
of this data in parallel.
So the MIG can scale
up very quickly,
and basically give
you all the machines.
You crunch through your
data and then it disappears.
Another use case that's
typical is things that
work around image processing.
So maybe you're getting a data
download of satellite imagery
or some other imagery that
comes maybe once a week.
And so again, you don't
need these machines six days
of the week.
But one day of the week
you need all of them
because you've got terabytes
of data to crunch through.
But each image can be
processed independently.
So that's a perfect use case.
So this is kind of like
distributed large scale data
processing.
And then another aspect that's
kind of orthogonal to this
but also important is this idea
of highly available services.
So whether that's your
web front end or even
your data processor,
you want to make sure
that the machines will
recover if they crash or hang
or have some other issues.
And you don't have to yourself
go in there and fix it.
So with auto healing you
can monitor these machines.
And if they run into trouble
your custom health check
will report on that and
the Managed Instance Group
will take care of this
and restart the machine.
And then the other side of
the highly available equation
is this concept that, if all
the machines are in one zone--
our zones are stable but at the
same time outages can happen.
And it is a best
engineering practice to say,
if you need a service to
be really, really stable,
you don't want to put all of
your machines in a single zone
because things can happen.
And so you want to spread
it across multiple zones.
And so now with a
Managed Instance Group
you can essentially
spread your machines
evenly across three zones.
So now we have something that's
called a regional Managed
Instance Group.
And we take care of this
problem of balancing.
So we'll add machines
and remove them as needed
so that each zone is
even to the other zones.
So if any one of
them disappears,
you can route your
traffic automatically
to the other zones and
not have any downtime.
So yeah.
It's anything that's
basically distributed,
independent, stateless, and then
highly available requirements
is the additional piece.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
So nowadays, most people when
they start thinking about,
I have specific needs, like
you were mentioning-- video,
processing, or big
data processing that
needs to be done quite fast.
Most people would think about
using things like Kubernetes.
What are the differences,
what are the benefits
of using Managed Instance Groups
or Managed Infrastructure,
as we call it, over going
with something like Kubernetes
or maybe even App Engine Flex?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: All right.
So let me take this one.
So all of these products,
or we call them engines,
are complimentary.
So you first need to
start from asking yourself
the question, how
much control do
I want to get versus how much
control do I want to give out?
And then we'll treat
everything automatic, right?
And from that perspective,
you have three choices, right?
You have App Engine or App
Engine Flex as one product.
It's best for the web
services of any kind.
It's the easiest to start.
There is some limitation
to the languages
that you can possibly use, but
you can load your custom Docker
containers and [INAUDIBLE]
it's the easiest
way for you to store it
on these kind of services.
Now when you want
some more control,
or when you want to control
the cost of performance
or when you want super
fast auto scaler,
right, this already
factors where
that would tip you towards
the Google Compute Engine.
So this is where you
have the Managed Instance
Group as a base service.
Right?
So Google Compute Englines
are just your VM machines.
So Google Compute
Engine specifically
is the platform on which App
Engine Flex is operating.
And it's also a platform on
which Kubernetes is operating.
Right?
So now, what
Kubernetes is adding
on top of Google Compute Engine
or a Managed Instance Group
is two factors, right?
It's the overall
container's orchestration
that contains of two
distinguishing factors, one
of which is bin packing
and the second one
is a general scheduling
slash microservices.
So these two cannot be done on
any of these other platforms.
Well they come as a service,
and what you have beneath
is a cluster of machines.
And these machines are likely
run by the Managed Instance
Groups.
MARK MANDEL: So I guess if
we are thinking about it
in terms of the compute
continuum, right?
And on far, we'll say, left.
Pick a direction.
That's like, platform
is a service App Engine.
Far right is GCE, like
straight-up infrastructure.
This sits, I feel
like, somewhere
between Kubernetes and GCE.
Like it sits in between
those two things,
where it's like it's not
entirely infrastructure
as a service and it's not nearly
as managed as, say, Kubernetes.
But sort of sits in
between and gives you
a bit more flexibility
than, say, Kubernetes.
But a little bit more that
you need to manage yourself.
Would that be pretty accurate?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: I
think it's very close.
I think you have to remember
that Managed Instance Group is
GCE.
This is exactly where we see it.
It's just a layer of
management on top of GCE.
But yes.
In terms of the
flexibility, this
is exactly where
you position it.
Like GCE is one more level
higher in terms of abstraction.
You give up some of
the control and you
gain a lot of management in
terms of backing and scheduling
the containers on top
of a cluster of machines
that you don't necessarily
need to manage yourself.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So let's imagine
that I decide to--
and actually I've
done it before.
I need a bunch of machines
running Image Magic, right?
And what I'm going to do
is, I create a new instance
and I connect to it.
I do APT CAD, install,
install Image Magic,
and now I install my
software on top of it.
And everything is
ready and it works.
Now normally if it
was in Kubernetes,
I could create a
docker image for that
and share that around, right?
How does that look on
Managed Instance Groups?
How do I make sure that
the new instances that
come into my Managed
Instance Group
have all the software and all
the features that I require?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Actually,
this is a very good question.
So similarly to what you
can do on both App Engine
and Kubernetes, you can
get all of your software
into a docker container
and then deploy it
into the Managed Instance
Group in a similar way.
The only difference is just
sitting as one container
on top of your VM.
So in that place comes the
need for deciding, very well,
how small your VM machine can be
so that your cost is optimized.
Everything else works the same.
And really creating a
Managed Instance Group
is strictly defining
what type of a machine
I want to run, right?
And then where do I pull
my docker container from.
And so once we have these
two parameters defined--
we define them in something I
would call Instance Template--
then you can create a group.
And once we have a group,
you can either tell it,
I want 100 instances,
1,000 instances,
2,000 instances of the same.
Or you can enable
auto scale and say,
I want the average CPU
utilization to be around 60%.
Or you can enable
auto healer and say,
if I don't hear from
this health check three
times in a row over a 30 second
period, consider it unhealthy
and please recreate
that instance for me
so that it continues operating.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So the question I'm
going to ask now--
it's going to make
me look very bad.
But I actually
didn't know you could
run docker containers directly
onto an instance group.
Do you need to choose a
specific image, a specific OS?
Or how does that work?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: This
is a very new feature.
It's actually in [INAUDIBLE].
So first of all, you have to
check on our documentation
or Google our
documentation and sign up.
And once you do, we'll enable
you, we will white list you.
And then the type of
image that runs there
is Google container image.
And it automatically
runs a docker contain.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So I feel less bad then.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So for those who aren't
necessarily part of the Alpha
program or have, probably,
an investment in,
say-- I will say traditional
DevOps type tools, so Chef,
Puppet, Ansible, TerraForm.
If people want to
use those tools to do
more of an installment directly
on the machines themselves,
how does that look?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: So
they can do it-- first
of all they can do it directly.
They can load the code directly,
the application directly
onto the machine using
just a startups grid
or baking an image, or
using Deployment Manager.
These are the tools that are
provided with the platform.
Right?
But obviously we are integrated
with Chef, Puppet, TerraForm,
Deployment Manager.
And all of these tools have
plug-ins or connections
so that you can use them
to deploy instances that
would be part of the
Managed Instance Group
and then would use all of
the goodies off the platform.
It's there.
You can find all of
the documentation
on our documentation page, along
with examples and some case
tests.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
We'll have links to all
of that documentation.
Do you have a
little bit of a view
on what are the tools that
people are actually using most?
Do people use a
lot of TerraForm,
or have you seen people
using Puppet mostly?
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: I'll jump in.
We've seen-- it's a fair mix.
I think the nice thing about
the Managed Instance Groups
is that, because they're
just built into GCE
itself and they're supported
by API, GCloud, and UI,
we have people using
Managed Instance Groups
from all of those entry points.
So you can basically just--
when you're starting out,
you can just go into the UI and
create an instance group based
on a template or-- create
an image, create a template,
create your own group.
And that's very
easy to get started
with because you can
see it, feel it, get
your hands dirty with
this very intuitive view
of the group of instances.
And then you can graduate,
if you want to, using GCloud
if you want to be doing
some simple scripting.
And then, of course, if you're
building something more solid,
you go to the API.
But then what we are seeing,
of course with Chef, Puppet,
is that people are creating
their own cookbooks
and scripts.
And we're looking at building
some of those on our own
as well so that we can really
support the Managed Instance
Groups as a first class citizen
of these different cookbooks.
So you can just create a group
and have it may be managed
externally, .
And then of course with
even our internal deployment
stack-- so like the
Deployment Manager--
you can use that to create
Managed Instance Groups
and that's another
common use case.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah that
is Mark's favorite product
of all Google Cloud platform.
He always talks about it.
MARK MANDEL: I do talk
about Deployment Manager.
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: Nice.
Nice.
Well we do like it.
MARK MANDEL: I just want people
to script their deploys, that's
all I want.
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ:
Infrastructure is code.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
there's something
that I think is really
cool, and most people
tend to forget, which is you
can actually create and manage
Instance Groups with
preemptible machines, right?
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: That's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
could you give us
a little bit about-- could
you talk to us a little bit
about what are the
benefits of these?
And real quick, why
people would use them?
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: I mean the
why is just to save money.
I mean that's-- the preemptibles
are there if you want to save
on cost.
But at the same time, if
you're willing to give up
the control of the instances.
And the nice thing is that
if you use Managed Instance
Groups you already
have this mindset of,
each instance is replaceable.
It's stateless.
I can create, destroy them,
because they'll just connect,
get their work, and do
it and then upload it
or do whatever needs to be done.
But each specific
instance isn't special.
And so if you
accept that mindset
and now you're writing a Managed
Instance Group with 2,000
instances, and any one of them
can be replaced at any time,
then suddenly
preemptibles makes sense.
Because maybe preempt a
bunch of them-- that's OK.
Because auto scaling or
whatever other automation
you have running will
just create new ones
and you can keep going
and keep working,
but you keep your savings.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
I just, for fun, I want to ask.
So what are the coolest
things you've seen
built on top of Managed
Infrastructures?
Has there been a
particularly awesome project
that you thought was
particularly fascinating?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: So we've seen
a couple of interesting events,
one of which was one of our
colleagues decided-- when
we first rolled out a beta
version of Auto Scaler,
one of our decided
we can actually
show on stage that we
can run back to serving
1 million words per second.
Right?
So we did an onstage demo,
pulling a load generator
and starting it, and then
creating from scratch a Managed
Instance Group running off
the shelf Abaci and loading it
with the load so that it
started adding instances.
And within six minutes,
it was adding--
the load was growing
gradually, right?
And within six minutes
we were already
supporting 1 million
words per second.
So can you beat that?
But one other
interesting story is
one of our customers, who was
migrating partly from on-prem
and partly from a different
cloud provider, was
having these spiky loads.
And this was an
application back end.
So it was super important
for this customer
not to lose these requests.
And this customer
came and said, look,
I really need a predictive
this auto scale.
And predictive auto
scaling is something
where you will be
able to say, tomorrow
at 7:00 AM I'm
going to have to use
this many instances of this.
And I'll automatically adjust.
And we didn't have
it at the time.
And they told us a story.
And the story was, well,
your competition also
didn't have it.
So we ended up
disconnecting auto scaler
around the time when
we most needed it.
And then we ended up adding
these instances manually
based on some back of
the envelope calculations
that we tracked
in a spreadsheet.
Right?
And it was a
terrible experience.
So I'll need like 10 minutes
after the peak has happened.
We were reconnecting
the auto scaler
so that it would do the clean
up and mostly scale down.
All that, right?
So they were miserable.
So we said, we'll be
happy to work with you.
But can you just
try our auto scaler?
And they said, no.
Look, you don't understand.
We've used the auto scaler
on your competitor's cloud
for years.
It's never going to
work in this condition.
And we said, OK.
We'll promise you we're going
to build it, but just try it.
Right?
And a couple of months
later, we got an email.
And the email was
just one sentence.
It said, "Predictive auto
scaling is no longer necessary.
Thank you."
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ:
Yeah, for mine
I think the coolest thing I see
is some of the things people
build with the
custom metric, right?
So auto scaling
everyone understands
to be CPU bound or based, or QPS
based-- which is like traffic.
But you can actually
code up your own metric,
which could be anything you
want at all, and scale on that.
And that's what some
of the customers
have been using to build
different cube-based scaling
solutions that are a
little bit smarter.
So that as the work comes in,
the metric gets calculated.
And then the auto scaler just
listens to that and then scales
up and down to
process the work you
have based on your own
definition of what work means
and how much time you need per
work unit and per instance.
And I think there's a lot
of flexibility with that
because you have that
full control of how
you calculate it.
And then we'll just scale it
based on how you want it scaled
and get through your work.
And then scale you down when
you don't need the machines.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I'm actually going to
add one more story.
MARK MANDEL: Go on, then.
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: Please do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We interviewed Tim Kelton
from the Descartes Labs,
or Descartes Labs depending on
how good or bad your accent is.
And they told us about how
they were processing terabytes
of Maps with Managed
Instance Groups,
and how they were very
happy with both the load
balancer, the auto scaling,
and the parental machines.
So if people are
interested in listening
to a whole story about
it, we have the episode 41
that you should check out.
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: Oh excellent.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well I think we're running
out of time just a little bit.
But I give you a
chance just if there's
anything that we
haven't mentioned
or maybe new things coming up.
Or basically anything
cool and exciting that you
want to make sure hits
our podcast listeners.
Is there anything
else you want to add?
Pawel, why don't you go first?
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: Sure.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
We're always working
on new things
and are excited to share them.
So on my side I want to
share the Updater, which
is now in alpha.
And it's also, like
the other future,
you have to be
[INAUDIBLE] to use it.
But it will be going
to beta very soon.
And so what the
Updater does is it
allows you to roll out a new
version of your software tier
Managed Instance Group in a
nicely controlled fashion.
So you can control the
rate of the update,
how many machines can be
offline at the same time,
how many machines to spin up
extra if you want to always
have your servers running.
Maybe you want to
do canary rollout
and do a partial rollout,
test it for a while.
So all of those
features are available,
which makes it super
easy to basically deploy
new versions of your
software onto your MIG
without disrupting your service.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And you, Jerzy?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Yeah.
Well the original
Managed Instance Group
are going GA-- just
very GA next week.
So you can count on all
of the great support
and SLA with all of the
services that we already
provided in beta.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Which may actually
already have gone GA,
depending on when we
release this podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think probably if it's
next week, probably yes.
So check it out.
Check the Google Cloud
block to make sure
if that announcement
has been out already.
Awesome.
Well thank you so
much to you two
for taking the time to
tell us a little bit more
about Managed Instance
Groups and tell us
about all the cool things
that people are building.
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ:
Thanks for having us.
It's always great to talk
Managed Instance Groups.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
Thank you.
Bye.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Thank you.
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: Thank you.
Bye.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks so
much to both Pawel and Jerzy
for such an
interesting interview.
I think that it is very
enlightening to see
not everything is Kubernetes.
You can go with GCE
and do many things.
And there's a lot of
features that will help
you make GCE very manageable.
That is a pun.
Because, you know--
MARK MANDEL: Because it's
Managed Infrastructure.
Yeah.
That's good.
I like that.
Well done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Get
MARK MANDEL: But I
think you're right.
You know, it just goes to that
whole continuum thing as well,
right?
If one of these
things isn't a fit
you've got so many
layers and so many levels
where you can come
in and be like, oh,
maybe I'll use
this particular one
and it'll be a better fit
for what it is I'm doing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And as I was saying that not
everything is Kubernetes,
let's go with a question of
the week about Kubernetes.
So the question is, OK, imagine
that I have a Kubernetes
cluster.
And I have a service
that I expose.
And I expose it to the world.
But I want to make sure
that only some specific IP's
or maybe a range of IP's
is able to access it.
How do I do that?
MARK MANDEL: So it's
actually surprisingly easy,
which is really, really cool.
You're able to restrict access
to a load balancer service
to an IP address range
in your YAML file,
in the same way as when
you define your service.
There is an argument in
there that you can set
called Load Balancer
Source Ranges.
It's a C-I-D-R. "Cedar"?
I don't know how
you pronounce that.
C-I-D-R?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
pronounce it "cider."
MARK MANDEL: Cider?
CIDR.
OK.
I can work with that.
It's one of those things
you read on the internet
but you never hear
someone say out loud.
So it's an IP range
format, for those
who aren't familiar with it.
So you can specify
what IP range you want.
So if you've got a specific
set, maybe a particularly white
listed IP or a particularly
white listed set of IP's.
Very simple to do that.
It ends up translating
behind the scenes
to being firewall specifications
inside Google Cloud.
And then only those IP addresses
can connect their services.
So you have better security if
you want only particular things
to access the services you
have available on Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I think that the important thing
is that, the same way we're
saying that you can do this
on Kubernetes very easily,
this ends up being translated
as just one more firewall rule
that will be applied to
the load balancer generated
on Google Compute Engine.
So if you want to do that by
yourself, you can also do that.
If you're not running
Kubernetes and you
want to limit the-- to constrain
the range of IP's that you're
exposing your service to, you
can use GCloud Compute Firewall
rules and do exactly the same.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
So it's all the same
things under the hood.
And if you're not
using Kubernetes on us,
maybe you're doing it on AWS,
it's supported there as well.
So that's pretty cool as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And the last thing is, if you
do this and for any reason
you're running Kubernetes
on a provider that
doesn't support this feature,
it will just be ignored.
So be careful with
that, I guess.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Excellent.
All right.
Well it sounds like that will
be the end of the episode, which
is a little sad.
But that's OK.
I will be joining
you shortly in LA.
But are you doing anything
before the end of the year,
or anything special going on?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not really.
I'm just back from
a week in China.
It was awesome.
We're going to be
this week here in LA.
And after that, I'm just going
to be enjoying my holidays.
I am actually getting
ready for two conferences
early next year.
At the end of January, I
will be in GoLab IO, which
will be in Florence, Italy.
And I'm excited
upset about that one.
And then in early
February, I'll be back
to one of my favorite
conferences, FOSDEM
in Brussels.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Yeah.
I think all I'm really
doing is ramping up
for Next end of Feb next year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And again,
Developers Conference
is just before that,
here in San Francisco.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just a
couple big things, you know?
MARK MANDEL: Just a
couple of big things.
Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well thank you, Mark, for
recording today remotely.
Well I guess I am the one
that is recording remotely.
But thank you anyway.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
Thank you too.
Thank you to everyone
who's listening to us,
and see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]